Brokers Club oh yeah what'd you guys
think it was awesome it was awesome yeah
so I was there on Saturday I was like
actually man dad had an accident hurt
his leg so I had to go back to Texas
because my mom was in India but I was
back there so I went to go back to help
him out just before she could come and I
was happy to be there and I was flying
out of Austin so I was like hey man I'm
flying out on Sunday like yeah dude
invited me to the club holy [__] I've
heard it's crazy it's great yeah yeah
it's
what's fun for me as an audience I mean
you guys get to perform right like I
actually get to like take it in and be
with the audience man it was it was fun
it's just like The Comedy Store it is it
is yeah it's it's an amazing thing okay
first of all I was like very against
Austin being a possible comedy City
interesting I just didn't think the math
worked out I was like there's like 300
000 people now I think there might be
like a million people to live in Austin
but like you want to pull that up
initially the population density just
wasn't there in my opinion for what I
thought right would be there right and
then an interesting thing happened like
oh wow what is it 2.2 million so this is
crazy yeah right now interesting thing
happens Austin has two million people it
has no professional sports teams yes I
don't consider the soccer team like a
professional massive well but it's not
professional yes it's a college team yes
that's fine but not professional the
only professional sport they have is
comedy ah comedy has become the
professional sport now add on the fact
that there is already a culture of going
out to listen to music live music that
is how people party that is how people
you go to the bar you listen to music it
is normal for them and it's always been
that way and it's always been that way
so it's normal for them to just go out
and indulge in live entertainment you
don't have to like train them that
that's part of their life there are some
cities where you have to train them
there's a reason why the comedy clubs
right now in New York right you have the
comedy seller we have the Village
Lantern where we would perform at
they're all in the same area what else
happens to that air there's live
entertainment right right and so when
people were going for live entertainment
maybe I'll check out music right but
training a people that it is normal to
go to a comedy show takes [__] time
yeah that's not quick yeah Miami I don't
know if they have like a live music
scene like let's go out and listen to me
you guys did well in Miami I I attended
that show I love it it's a little bit
different because we're we're not the
average okay yeah yeah starting out at
it exactly okay what I would say about
Miami is a perfect example like Miami is
Latin Americans version of America in
the same way that like Hawaii is Asians
version of America so the things that
exist and are popular in Latin America
are going to succeed in Miami baseball
yes we're into it soccer we're into it
yeah club nights going out of dancing
basketball keep games are empty yes
because basketball is not it's not part
of it a cultural thing in Latin America
right and you'll see the exact same
thing happen in Hawaii so you have this
group of people that like going out they
like being entertained it's like perfect
for that right you have these clubs that
start to get built up and then you have
the biggest name in media that moves
there and he's like I'm gonna put
everything into this [__] club and he
makes this great Club the crazy thing a
lot of people don't even notice about
the club it's like Rogan's like I don't
even care if it makes money yeah I know
yeah he's like I just want to break even
you can't compete with that yeah I know
you can't it's like it's he he goes I
just want it I just want it to break
even think about that he doesn't need to
make money dude he won't let me say what
it is but he said I could talk kind of
about it
but the way that he's playing Comics
it's bananas bro bananas it's like it's
just complete Game Changer huh like I
don't know how the other clubs will
react yeah because they're in it to make
money and he's developed a model where
it's like he it's like he doesn't want
to make it to be fair he's like I'm
still gonna do the Vulcan I'm still
going to do like freak in the case which
is the sweetest thing which is very nice
here's the other this is the other thing
that's crazy this is
if you work at the club a lot of people
that work at the club are Comics you can
check out your shift to go to a spot
and then come back in the other place in
another place that's wild yeah and then
come back in and the other place can't
be mad because Rogan will still perform
at your Venue yeah
yes he like took money from Spotify and
his glittery Distributing it to comics
in in an insane way so it's like this
crazy kind of situation you haven't even
seen before and now you have all these
other like down the block there's the
Vulcan another block away there's the
creek there's another comedy club that's
coming up a couple blocks so in this one
space you can pop around and do five or
six spots only New York can you do that
you can't do that in La really oh I
guess you drive this car you're driving
maybe you make it make sense it's like a
trickier thing to do you can hit the
three clubs maybe and then you're making
what 75 bucks in that night maybe yeah
in perspective I only did the little
room when I went and I did like four
shows there and I made money on the trip
also pay for my flight so that helps
yeah but even if I wasn't trying to
profit it's very easy to make money
right I've been doing this for a while
yeah people are getting that again
paid to perform
down there what is this about even if I
did pay for it though I still would have
made money requests
[Laughter]
um but yeah it was just like I don't
know he's he's just doing he's creating
a [__] it's just an insane thing to do
and the way he described it was so cool
he was like people always think oh when
you're a kid and you make a bunch of
money you're like oh what am I going to
do with it you have all these crazy
ideas he literally was like yeah I'm
just gonna do that yeah I'm gonna do the
thing like I'm gonna make a comedy club
with all my friends and pay them also I
asked him
I was like why have you not been caught
up in like just the the bitter like
jealousy and like and like rage that so
often happens within the entertainment
industry like it's very con like actors
[__] hate each other comedians
[__] hate each like how the hell are
you just so supportive of everybody you
want everybody to win and he was like
martial arts uh cause he's a very
competitive dude right yeah oh yeah like
Rogue is a [__] insanely competitive
dude but with comedy he's competitive
but at the same time he wants everybody
to win and everybody succeed and he's
like it's martial arts he's like it's a
different thing happens when you're like
training with your brothers you guys are
going at it you're literally trying to
tap each other out while at the same
time helping each other get better get
better yeah that makes sense and it's
like you can do that with comedy and
that kind of made sense it was the only
thing that made sense why he was this
way you need that instilled in you from
another discipline and you need proof
that it works yes and you do get better
Jiu Jitsu when you're training with a
guy that's better than you and it
doesn't take away from that guy's
Jujitsu his doesn't get worse because
you get better yes he might even get a
little bit better yeah and when I kind
of saw like that and we explained like
that I was like oh this is this is
[__] awesome both rooms are great
they're they're great for different
reasons that little room is great
because it allows you to to develop
connection you can learn how to like
lock in with an audience you're not
necessarily just kind of speaking at
them oftentimes in big rooms you can get
away with just speaking at them right
you do a theater you're not connecting
especially if you're a young comic
developing in like theaters like you're
not really connecting right there's 3
000 people just laughing at you when you
have 40 people or 100 people or whatever
that room is you gotta look them in the
eyes you can't fake them
you can't be a phony in front of a small
crowd and then the big room reminds me
of the store and you learn how to
perform so once you learn how to connect
in that little room now you go to the
big room and you learn how to perform
you learn how to fill space A lot of
times people you know if you if you only
develop in small rooms you don't know
how to handle a room that has a thousand
seats like a cacophony of exactly it's a
different energy you don't know you
don't know the breathing of an audience
in a room that size you know how to
build that tension and then like release
it you know they're different Arts that
really that rarely you're able to do
both in a night
that is true and able to see the
difference in both you know what I'm
saying yeah sure so a young comic that's
going to develop there is going to get
like a really well-rounded experience
this is the death of LA
and also do you have any other cities
where this could happen even if there's
no Rogan I have a I have a possible
candidate in mind but not having Rogan
could be big so death of La I don't know
I this is what I think I think if that
if you're once this pay scale is out
there in the world which it will happen
it will once
if you're a young comic are you going to
come to New York
and toil away in obscurity for four
years
in destitute poverty and being in New
York bridge is the [__] being new or
poor it's not for even America I've been
poor in New York I swear so many times I
was like this is not America like I'm
sleep there's so many [__] mice
running by my face all like this is not
the America my parents were promised and
for that same money you were living okay
maybe in a part of it but in Texas in
Austin's an expensive city in Texas yes
it's you can live a good life
30 minutes
in a car you'll have a car out there
much easier so live in a suburb live in
Pflugerville Drive in who gives a [__]
right right Pflugerville is a place you
would you would know if you were texting
but it's like most people who just moved
Austin
so you went there yeah yeah I did yeah
he drove through it yeah I drove three
yeah you you're so much better at Austin
so my gripes are from Texas you know
what I mean
um but the candidate I think potentially
real quick just to finish that that idea
is like so do you come here and then
compete with the best comics in the
world
for stage time which is going to be very
difficult
or do you go to a new city where the
best comics in the world haven't moved
there yet and the new ones haven't
developed into it yet their stage time
and money and seven clubs without the
same level of competition so if you're a
brand new comic do you go there for four
years before you come to New York right
do you go there for four or five years
before you go to La and try to be you
know in sitcoms or whatever the [__] you
want to do do you learn and develop your
craft in this place
it to me I'm like wow that is a very
intriguing possibility but do you think
that you guys like for the whole like
iron sharpens iron like do you think he
was better off you guys came up in
Cutthroat New York for me it was like
you made it but I think yeah it's
actually made it which is crazy us yeah
like yes but you have to understand like
most comics
aren't going up against iron early in
their life they're at Open Mic I was
do what listen No but you get ass you
but but for real and you too and there's
we were lucky we had some people but
like one of the most valuable things we
had was barking and yeah that means
handing out tickets in exchange for
stage time yeah I don't know if that
exists to the same level that existed
when we were there no like I with every
oh it felt like almost every Club
allowed you to like bark for stage time
the beauty of that is you got to go up
with iron yes you got to follow a Greer
Barnes when you were a year in comedy
and you got to see what is amazing and
what is not even [__] close when
you're just doing open mics or you're
doing like shows that are like you know
privately book shows you're going up
with people around your level right
right and living with rats and destitute
yes
so it's like and like if you're from
Indiana do you come here and just do
that for four years or do you go to
Austin develop a little bit of an act
yeah and then when it's ready to go up
against some iron come here or if you
get lucky you're a door guy there and
then you're following Tony Hinchcliffe
yeah well additionally because Rogan has
got the top thing there it's gonna
Foster I think ideally an environment
where everybody helps everybody in that
martial arts style he talked about that
didn't exist in New York I think he
helped me a lot I try to help as much as
I could here but like well yeah
right like this right here most of
Comedy is an isolated uh you have
blinders on you just get funny Austin
could potentially be a community where
everybody helps everybody and builds
everybody Logan will make that happen
and they are though bro like I saw I got
off stage and like one of the door guys
I never really met before was like dude
here's a tag here's something you can
maybe try with that joke like it felt
very communal yeah because they all
identify as Mothership guys they're like
yo yeah we are Mothership dudes they
were all very cool I got to meet some of
them afterwards I was like damn man and
they're all [__] funny that that's
actually the key I was like yesterday
the trans episode
but yeah no Derek I mean like watching
him he [__] murdered
I won't ruin it the TSA bit which he
does he's [__] amazing but yeah it's
just like yeah seeing a guy like that
start so that's your like up and coming
class there and now those guys instead
of like thugging it out through open
mics not really knowing if the material
is going to work for a real audience now
they have sold out shows to go up in
front of every single night so if
they're that good now yeah imagine what
happens two years from now three years
from now it's like yeah and because Joe
is not so concerned with making money
he's able to be like oh this guy is
super talented but he's not like perfect
yet but let's put him up in the little
room a bunch and really like train him
and get him good because he's not so
concerned with like oh are people gonna
come back are they going to keep paying
tickets to come back his name they'll be
buying it for the next three straight
years it's funny I was like yeah I told
my friends I'm like yeah they're like
how did you get tickets
and think about it's like every weekend
a new person pops in yes yeah yeah like
Tim Dylan's down there right now that's
right we're down there during the week
Shane's there Chappelle's popping in
it's like every week in a new random
massive Act is just gonna drop in yeah
and this of the appeal of the seller
anybody could drop in yeah the appeal of
Joe Rogan's Club anybody good job yes
financially it makes sense and the Hang
is awesome like Joe takes care of
everyone yeah like you go down there in
the Sweet Bar the mitzi's bar downstairs
everyone's hanging it just feels cool
New York and La scenes are completely
different you don't need it like you
used to but what but yeah but what Rogan
what Rogan has done and I hope it
happens in other Industries but it
really just takes somebody willing to do
it and the reality is in competitive
Industries like comedy like news like
anything you're fighting for what you
believe are scraps yeah so you don't
think there's more to go around right
right and that's why there never is
anybody who does it yes and then the
person who's willing to do it he is
novel and that is why we talk about him
you know in this way so often in the
show it's just like it is [__] unique
I wish people knew like what the real
comedy world was it's it's a lot of like
you're dapping somebody up you're
talking to them they're talking trash
about their best friend yeah right to
you yeah you're like I I know you guys
are friends why would you talk about him
like that what are you gonna say this
way the George Lopez clip didn't
surprise yeah most probably you use
people definitely if you're a comic
you're like yeah nothing was you know
it's I mean I'm not it's just rare that
you see somebody like organized like
this and then reward the people that are
working hard the people are good and
also continuing that culture like if
there's a selfish [__] who's
just out there for you know what they
can get out of it and like squashing
everybody else please believe that
person is not rewarded you know what I
mean like like they're not gonna get on
they're not gonna get promoted you guys
aren't going to have them on it's not
gonna be like